오늘 비사남이 간다 이태원에
왔습니다. 그래서 한 3, 4개월
만에 온 거 같은데 그 3, 4개월
사이에 정말 엄청난 이슈들이
있었어요. 그래서 그 이후에 상권이
좀 어떻게 변했고 좀 지금 상황이 좀
어떤지 한번 좀 보도록 하겠습니다.
여기 건너 가지고 여기 뒷꼬목부터
한번가 보도록 하겠습니다. 가시죠.
실 지금 시간에는 많이 없어요.
그래서 보통 이제 저녁 시간대 그때
이제 사람이 좀 많고 지금 시간대는
사실 사람이 없습니다. 여기 다 이제
술 파는 곳이기 때문에 유동인구가
그렇게 많지 않고 올 때 저기 한남동
쪽도 보긴 했지만 한남동 쪽에는
사람이 많아요. 꼼대가라르 손길이랑
거기 카페가 카페 거리 쪽에 사람이
되게 많은데 여기는 상대적으로 그렇게
사람이 한남동보단 많지 않은 거
같습니다. 그리고 여기는 그래도 뭐가
좀 들어와 있는데 저쪽 편에는 그래도
아직도 많이 비어 있어요. 그래서
지금 상권 상황이 좀 좋지 않은 거
[음악]
같습니다. 그리고 여기 이면에는
공실은 없어서 흘럽거리라고 하는데
여기 이제 그래도 밤에 되면 사람이
되게 많습니다. 그래서 여기까지는
그래도 좀 임차인도 꽤 많이 차 있고
상권이 그나마 좀 괜찮긴 하지만 녹사
평력 쪽으로 가면 갈수록 공실은 되게
좀 높아진 거 같습니다. 개인적인
생각은 이태원 살레 한남동 살례 하면
저는 무조건
한남동입니다. 우리가 지금 이태원에
오긴 했지만 어 그래서
한남동이 어 뭐 건물 가격 오르는
것도 그렇고 그 상권도 거기 꼼대가
메인 쪽은 공실이 그렇게 많이
없어요. 거기 이면에 한남동 카페리도
공실이 없을 정도로 많이 차했습니다.
뭐 워낙 요즘에 다양한 상건들이 많고
좋은 상권들이 많다 보니까 이런 쏠림
형상들이 되게 커지는 거 같습니다.
그래서 특히 여기 같은 경우에는
한남동 쪽으로 더 가거나 아니면
성수동을 가거나 약간 그런 젊은
사람들이 더 많아진 거 같고 공석
씨가 운영하던 가게가 이제 여기 원래
마이첼 씨가 여기 있었는데 요것도
이제 임차인이
바뀌었고 여기 일대일 되게 많았는데
다 가게를 뺐습니다. 그 정도로 지금
상권이 예전이랑 좀 많이 달라진 거
같고.
근데 저는 개인적으로 이렇게 먹자
상권에 있는 건물이 왜 이렇게 뭔가
내키지가
[음악]
않 여기 일대 뭐 이렇게 개발 호재들
되게 많잖아요. 뭐 용상공원
개발이라든지 뭐 한남유타운
개발이라든지 이런 호재들 때문에 뭐
여기 일대가 좋아질 거라는 얘기를
하긴 하지만 저 개인적으로는 사람들이
대로를 안 넘어옵니다. 여기 뒤에
바로 생기지 않은 이상은 여기 상권이
영향을 엄청 받을 가능성은 좀 그렇게
좀 크지 않다라고 생각을 합니다.
거기 일대가 개발되고 하면은 뭐
이렇게 유동 인구라든지 이런게 더
많아질 수는 있겠지만 한남동 상권이랑
워낙 가깝기 때문에 저는 오히려 좀
더 한남동 쪽으로 가지 않을까 그렇게
예상을 하고 있습니다. 근데 물론
이제 이태원동 쪽도 저는 여기 쪽
길은 괜찮다라고 생각은 해요. 근데
이제 여기 좀 벗어날수록 상권이 많이
죽은 거 같습니다. 만약에 이태
운동에 투자하실 생각이 있다라고 하면
여기 메인길만 보셨으면 좋겠어요.
그리고 여기 뒤쪽으로 가면 그
경리단길이랑 뭐 그쪽에 있긴 하지만
거기도 지금 좀 공실이 많거든요.
그리고 지금 시세도 좀 많이 내려가고
있고 지금 이태원역 여기 대로는
최근에 팔린게 뭐 평당 한 1억 한
초중반 정도의 매각이 되더라고요.
그래서 진짜 그 정도 가격이면 예전에
호황일 때 가격보다 더 저렴하거나
아니면 그때 당시 가격이랑 비슷한데
빌딩 가격이나 이런게 좀 많이 오르지
않은 거 같습니다. 임대료 수준도
무엇보다 되게 높아지거나 그런게
아니기 때문에 아마 빌딩 가격이 좀
정체돼 있지 않나 그렇게 예상을 하는
반면에 한남동은 그래도 빌딩 가격도
계속 오르고 있고 그리고 임대료
수준도 계속 오르고 있어서
개인적으로는 둘 중에 어디 투자할래
하면은 저는 한남동 쪽을 더 투자하지
않을까? 제가 앞서 계속 설명드렸던
부자분들이 많이 사는 동네 부동산에서
사야 되거든요. 그래서 공급은 한정돼
있고 부자분들이 좋아하는 동네 뭐
나인원이라든지 한남 더일이라든지 뭐
유빌리지라든지 거기 워낙 고급 주거가
많기 때문에 개인적으로는 이태원보다
지금 한남동이 좀 더 좋지 않나
그렇게 생각을 합니다. 아 그게
아니고이 사람이 참 잘 모르시네.
무슨 말씀하시는지. 아, 이태원이
지금 낮이서 사람이 없는데 제가
30대 초반부터 이태원에 오래 살아
가지고 사람들이 보통 저녁에 보통
1차를 먹고 나서 2차를 이쪽에서
와서 하거든요. 보통 보시면
아시겠지만 여기 식당은 없고 다
펌이라 라운지로 이루어져 있기 때문에
지금 사람 없다고 해서 전혀 사람
없는게 아닙니다. 아, 저는
한남동보다 이태월 더 좋습니다. 아,
그래요? 네. 사실 그 이태원
토박이시고 단점이 지금 사토리.
저도 뒤따라 들었었는데이 뒤쪽에 뭐
프로프트라든지 뭐 글램 라운지 있고
예전에는 이태훈 앞에 뭐 B1이라든지
클럽들 많 있었거든요. 지금도 오셔서
보셔서 아시겠지만 지금도 아직
파운테인이 있긴 하더라고요. 제가
했을 때 파운테인이 가장 좀 유명한
데였고 거기서 사람들이 술 마시고
보통 거기 가서 이제 클럽 가서 이제
만나 예. 춤추고 어 춤추고 움주고
또
지금 사람이 없는 거지. 근데 저녁에
사람들이 많고 제 친구들도 이쪽
이태원 다시 살아나서 이태원에 많이
온다고 하더라고요. 그래서 사실 여기
클럽이 제일 유명하잖아. 아, 클럽도
유명하고요 앞에도 지금 원래 홍석 씨
식당이요 앞에도 뭐 그때 타이집인가
있었었거든요. 아, 마이 타이. 예.
마이 타이 한 10열 개 정도
있었는데 그거 다 없어진 거 같고
그리고 바로 위쪽에 예전에 냉장고
부탁해 외국인 셰프 미카일인가 하는
오빠가 바로 위에 있긴 하거든요. 저
위쪽에 보이는게 이해영 씨 매입해서
저 위에 저 코너에 있는 거 예. 저
위에 있는 여기도인데 안에 그거 당고
테이블 있거든요. 그런 문화들이 좀
많이 있긴 해. 여기 한국인들이 잘
모르는게 잘 안 하긴 하니까 사람들은
당구 매 저 수리쿠션 한 200에서
250치 나가 아 잘 치시나 저희
스타그래프트 안 하고 전 당구장
다녔던 세대여 가지고 아예 못 아 못
치세요? 아 못 금다 안가 봤어요.
아 그럼 클럽 한번 가보죠 저희
갑자기 못 들어가는 못 들어가겠죠.이
이 건너편에도 지금 여기 녹사편
사거리 여기에도 지D가 생일 파티
여기서 있었었거든요. 요 밀크였나
지금 기억이 안 났는데 저쪽에 클럽
있는지 모르겠는데 그쪽에도 사람들
많이 있고 클럽 때문에 사람들이
이쪽에 많이 오긴 하죠. 사실 저는
그랬던 거 같아요. 여기 클럽의
장점이 뭐예요? 외국인도 많이 오고
사실은 나이제한이 사실 딱히 억게하건
홍대 같은데 가면 나이가 이제
20대에 막 이렇게 어린 나이가
있다면 사실 이태원은 30대에 뭐
40대도 있고 뭐 그냥 놀러 오신
분도 있고 외국인도 많고 해서 그냥
다양한 문화가 좀 섞여 있어 가지고
저는 외국인 친구들 특히나 영화학원
선생님이라든지 유치원 선생님라든지
대학교 교수라든지 그런 분들 좀 많이
알았어 가지고 그런 친구들 커뮤니티
때문에 이쪽에 많이 놀러왔던 거
같아요. 또 뭐 미국 부대도 예전에
있었어 있던 그죠. 그래서 외국인
미국인 노방 그랬던 거
[음악]